hello my name is chin monirkay
this is the itcs 2022 version of our
talk
a circuit lower bounds for low energy
states of code hamiltonians this is
joint work with anurag anshu who while
the work was being completed was at uc
berkeley and is now a professor at
harvard
the starting point for this talk
is the complexity of low energy states
for local hamiltonians
while ground states of local
hamiltonians are known to be these
highly entangled non-classical objects
that simultaneously capture universal
quantum computation and describe
quantum mechanics
the complexity of their low energy
counterparts
is sort of strange ground states
are these amazing mathematical objects
which sort of bridge our understanding
of computer science and physics and yet
their low energy counterparts which are
more physically realizable are something
we don't have as good mathematical
understanding over
so an overarching goal of what we want
to do in this line of research is we
want to understand the complexities of
these higher energy state systems
how entangled are they how non-classical
are there and do they capture universal
quantum computation these questions are
interconnected to a variety of questions
in quantum complexity theory ranging
from the quantum pcp conjecture to more
practical ideas and constructions of
quantum devices
but today we'll focus on very simple
very small section of that
research world and i will sort of
mathematically
make these kind of more
broad points rigorous
so
to
get a little bit more technical we start
by thinking about the almost a decade
old conjecture now by friedman hastings
called the nlps conjecture or no low
energy trivial states conjecture
which states that there should exist
local hamiltonians for which every state
of low energy is highly entangled and
non-classical and i will in due course
be specific as to what it means to be
low energy what it needs to be highly
entangled and what it means to be
non-classical
at a high level though this nlts
conjecture is stating a property that we
expect
is contained by some local hamiltonians
but this is not a property you expect of
your garden variety local hamiltonians
so sort of the physically realizable
local hamiltonians we naturally think
about will not have this property
and yet we expect that these properties
should be mathematically constructable
of some family of local hamiltonians
which is why
sort of this very fascinating
problem because it connects sort of the
engineering of local hamiltonians
to notions of physical physicality
what these hamiltonians will have is
properties is they will have no
classical approximations for their
ground states and you can think of them
in the following sense that a state that
was brought from a ground state where
it's highly entangled up to room
temperature will still preserve some of
these notions of high entanglement that
we wish to see
our goal
is to be precise in these things and
prove for a certain definition of highly
entangled and non-classical
such as the statement more specifically
we're going to use the notion of circuit
depth as a measure of entanglement and
non-classicality or more generally
complexity and what we will show is a
circuit depth lower bound for every low
energy state for a certain family of
local hamiltonians
the family of local hamiltonians we'll
be interested in
are arising from error correcting codes
so you might look at this talk if you're
interested in just error correction
theory or coding theory or you might
look at this in terms of a more general
quantum complexity perspective and i
hope that people from both kind of
crowds gain something from this talk
so now the very technical mathematical
statement is the following so if you
consider a
stabilizer quantum error correcting code
so that's a quantum error correction
code whose check terms are all defined
by stabilizer
matrices or
paulie matrices
um and let's see be an nkd code so n
being the number of physical cubits k
being the number of logical cubes and db
ratio distance
then
if you consider the local hamiltonian
that corresponds to this code so there's
one local term which checks
for every code
every code term
whether it's being satisfied or not
then what we get is that for any low
energy state rho
so low energy here being an epsilon
fraction of the total energy the total
energy of course being on the order of n
then the circuit depth of rho
scales at least with log of d and log of
this other term which i will save in a
second and let's note that log of d is
sort of the optimal answer we could get
because we know that for stabilizer
error correcting codes there exists
ground state of log v circuit
now the part that's missing here
is the following it's actually based on
the rate
so we get that when the code has high
rate so when the rate of the code is on
the order of n
we get a circuit lower bound that's
non-trivial for energy almost
a constant fraction
and actually we can actually strengthen
this result to be of the following
whereas either the rate or the distance
needs to be good in order for us to get
a circuit lower balance but for the
interest of this talk we will only focus
on the simplified version of the
statement where it's just log k over n
here but if you are interested in the
full version you can
read our paper where you'll see how it's
log k plus d
so another way of looking at this result
through examples and here's a simple
example that if you have a linear rate
code where that's where the rate k
scales
with
n but the distance need not be actually
linear it could be polynomial distance a
simple example being like the t like
z-more codes
then for all states of energy
on the order of n to the point 99 so
just slightly sub-linear
the circuit complexity of those state
scales like log n so it's up to a
constant factor optimal
another way of writing this is that if
the energy is like little o of n then
the circuit complexity is super constant
so a little context in terms of prior
work
but we had prior to this result known of
a circuit lower bound for all low energy
states
um
that was that was non-trivial other than
first the small energy graph of order n
to the negative two and this result
follows from some from the work of
kitayas on circuit to hamiltonian clock
construction
log n
depth lower bounds were known for very
restricted subclasses of low energy
states such as epsilon error states by
work on by elder and hero and myself
with umeshwazrani and henry us or
one-sided error by the original authors
of the nlts conjecture gibbs states and
z2 symmetry
so to contextualize our result this
might be illustrator to think about some
example codes for which our lower bounds
actually hold the first one is one i
just mentioned a second ago that being
the telegr more hypergraph product
these are codes for which the rate is
linear the distance scale is like square
root of n in which case we're able to
prove lower bounds
as previously stated of log n for any
state of energy n to the point 99 or
less
another interesting and non-trivial
example is the punctuator code where we
puncture an almost linear number of
holes in this case n to the one minus
delta where delta is a small constant
if you do puncture this whole it's not a
difficult mathematical exercise to
realize the rate is also almost linear
and the distance is polynomial so what
you get is a circuit lower bound that
scales with delta times log n for all
states of almost linear energy
a sort of surprising result because we
don't expect these sort of complexity to
exist
in such a two-dimensional code in fact
we know for a fact that states
that sit on a two-dimensional lattice
like the punctuator code cannot be the
complete nlts theorem i recognize that i
haven't formally stated what the nlts
theorem is so excuse me nlts conjecture
is and i will state that in due course
a third
example code is one that's very recent
which is the tantalum college have ldpc
codes from just last year um
which are codes of linear rate and
linear distance unfortunately the
result that we are able to prove
is only a constant factor better for the
ponte lev college have ldpc code than it
is for the felix female hypergraph
product codes and there isn't actually a
order of magnitude uh
better lower bound we're able to prove a
very interesting thing
um future work
is to try to understand if there is
something to be gained from their
construction that actually strengthens
the arguments we're presenting today and
actually able to prove the nlts
conjecture
perhaps before we go on to how we prove
our result or contextualize it more in
terms of the quantum pcb conjecture it's
illustrator to first think about why the
result is surprising
quantum error correcting codes are
designed to correct discrete errors
defined by the physical qubits they are
not designed in mind or at least the
original formulation by shore
for error correction did not have in
mind these sort of undiscrete errors
that are
errors analogous to low energy states
in contrast what we actually show is
that despite the definition
not handling such continuous errors
low energy states which violate these
kind of clauses fractionally and these
are larger look kind of energy errors
and cannot be defined discreetly are
still analyzable
using the definition of error correction
and have interest in quantum properties
and
by doing so we show that
the discretized model for error
correction
may
have more benefit in the non-discrete
model than we had previously done
so to contextualize the problem
let's look back at the quantum pcp
conjecture
the quantum pcb conjecture is a nice
pictorial example where let's start with
n qubits this
sitting on a line but they need not be
in a line where we have hamiltonian
terms h1 and h2 these terms again need
not act on the line just act on some
constant number of terms each
given that there is a mathematical
hermitian operator the local hamiltonian
operator which is the sum of these local
terms and it acts on n cubits
and
for every local hamiltonian
there is a value the minimum energy
which is the infimum over all states
that trace h5
and now a simple computational question
is given a description of each of these
vocal hamiltonians and which cube it's
an axon how hard is it to compute e up
to some accuracy epsilon
and
it's well known
by kitayas
that when the epsilon that you're trying
to calculate the accuracy to is one over
n squared then this problem of computing
e
is qma hard
and
kitaj is the original result had it for
one over n cubed but then
uh following results have actually
improved that to one over n squared
the quantum tcp conjecture says it's
actually hard to compute it even when
the epsilon is on the order of n
and um for references you can look at
the wonderful surveys by ahernav arad
and vince
so this problem the quantum tgp
conjecture has been around for almost 20
years now and in some ways we are no
closer to solving it now than we were
when we started
it is a problem that eludes and excites
us in the community all the time but
there was a simplification of this
problem called the nlts conjecture the
no low energy trivial states conjecture
which tried to grab at a very simple
property
of the quantum pcb
conjecture and we state this now because
even this conjecture has been open for
almost a decade
to process the nlts conductor we first
have to formalize what we mean by
circuit depth just by having talked
about it for almost five minutes now
so
for any given state psi
the circuit depth of psi is the minimum
depth when you get to stack two cubits
local gates where the gates can be any
two qubit unitary say and any
connectivity even though pictorially i
draw this two-dimensionally but any
connectivity
um
such that once you trace out some
fraction of the cubits the resulting
state is exactly psi on those registers
the nlcs conjecture says that there
exists some fixed constant epsilon think
like 1 over 100
and a family of local hamiltonians h
which act on n cubits such that for all
states of low energy so all states have
energy less than 1 over 100 of the total
state if that's one of one over 100 but
the circuit complexity of those states
must be super constant
super constant meaning that it scales
with n and it's not a
fixed constant
so pictorially something like this that
when states are
low energy you know the complexity is
super constant and up to some barrier it
stays super constant and then after that
you know
doesn't matter and that
that's sort of what happens to be
because all states have some energy
somewhere right
so as i'll show in a second the nlts
conjecture is a necessary consequence of
the quantum pct conjecture and
in many ways it's much easier because it
separates the robustness of entanglement
question of the nlts of the quantum pcb
conjecture
from the hardness of computation aspect
quantum pcp is the statement both about
computation at the same time quantum
complexity here in the nlts question
note has nothing to do with computation
the hamiltonians need not be physically
relevant for any sort of computational
task they just are hamiltonians
that possess some notion of robust
entanglement entanglement which persists
even at a low energy state
in some sense it asks about the ability
to conduct quantum computation at room
temperature ask can i produce a
hamiltonian so that even if i let the
system thermalize the states that remain
after thermalization are still complex
and entangled
so our result in the context of nlts is
a circuit lower bound for a specific
family of local hamiltonians
note that this nlts conjecture asks for
circuit lower bounds for all states of
energy
less less than some fixed constant and
our lower bound
has a scaling with the constant epsilon
so we are unable to achieve the exact
parameters of the nlts conjecture but we
get something that is arbitrarily close
and in some sense a small improvement on
our results would be enough to prove the
nots conjecture
so part two of this talk now that we've
sort of set up the goal of what our
result is and contextualize it in terms
of
the lts conjecture is to first prove the
basic setup that will allow us to
mathematically
show our results at least
so a version of our results for the
purposes of this talk
so
one more time circuit complexity
is the minimum depth of any circuit that
exactly produces the state run
and some simple facts about circuit
complexity is that if the circuit
complexity is less than one if and only
if the state is a tensor product
statement
a simple other factor we'll use is that
if you have a constant locality
hamiltonian and a state of low circuit
complexity here is going to be some
complexity t where t is a small number
then there's a classical algorithm for
exactly computing the energy
of that state rho with respect to that
hamiltonian h in time that scales
polynomially in the number of qubits and
w exponential in t
the idea is that we're going to show
that each term of the hamiltonian h i
rho
h being a linear sum of them so it's
just so trace of h rho is just the sum
of trace h i rho
will only depend on the reduced
computation on order two to the t qubits
and if there's order two to the t cubits
then that can be calcium simulated in
time two to the two to the t that's the
rough sketch and we'll show that in a
second
to show that
we need to first introduce the notion of
light cones so lycone is a very simple
idea
so it says basically the following that
if i had indicate a wire i
then the like cone of that wire is all
the wires for which there is an
information propagation so you can see
that if given this wire i that's drawn
here all the wires corresponding to the
output of one of these gray gates
could be
could possibly
be correlated with the value of the wire
at i the value at one of these non
uh
gray gates cannot be because information
can only travel according to the
propagation of the units
so a simple property we can see is the
size of the light cone
is on the order of two of the t two just
coming from the fact that we're talking
about two cubic unitaries if you're
talking about three cubic unit terms
would be three right that this these
constants actually will not end up
mattering in our talk
the second fact we're going to use is a
sort of technical fact
about light cones which says that if i
have
a low depth circuit u here u
being of depth t
and i have a density matrix or any
operator row actually
if i want to look at
the value on the highest qubit of row so
here my notation of trace minus i is
means i'm going to trace out all the
qubits except for that iq
then the value of this
term
can actually be simplified by just
looking at the reduced density matrix of
rho on that light cone li so
recall i is going to be the name of some
wire or some qubit and li is going to be
the set of qubits which are its like
we'll provide this proof on the next
page because this will be one of our two
crucial
theorems that we're going to use in our
proof statement
okay so how do we prove this thing well
it's actually not too difficult let's
there's a very nice pictorial proof that
we'll see in a second so let a be any
operator that acts on the iq
okay so then if i wanted to calculate
the value of a acting on that i qubit i
could write that as trace of a times the
value on that i cubit and now using the
fact that i know the trace of a partial
trace i can just write in this other
form right
and now i'm going to prove that this
actually is equal to trace u dagger a u
rho l i how do i do that well let's
first draw the first one let's draw a
trace of u dagger a you row it looks
like this here's rho on the outside
there's a in the middle you dagger on
one side u on the other
and now let's notice that all the white
gates are right across from their
adjoint they're they're inverse right so
they just cancel each other out so all
i'm left with is the gates that only
acted in the light cone and the reduce
and row
i'm taking the reduced density matrix on
which is exactly what the statement is
so i get the statement on the left
so this is a simple pictorial proof of
the equation with the left
and now i can just undo this partial
trace right and rewrite it this way
and since this holds for any operator a
i didn't have to do anything with
regards to a
then fact 2 follows immediately
okay so this actually is enough for us
to understand why the quantum piece
speed conjecture implies nlts
and previously when i said it directly
implies that lts i was kind of cheating
a bit it's modular the well
assumed statement np does not equal qma
so how do we do this well let's take the
simplified version of the quantum pcp
you can do it for all technical versions
that you want let's just say you're
given a local hamiltonian
answering if minimum energy is exactly
zero or greater than one over ten n
let's assume that was qma hard
and let's assume simultaneously that
nlts was false it said for every epsilon
greater than zero and every local
hamiltonian there is a state of constant
circuit complexity where the circuit
complexity scales with epsilon so it's
like you know but for fixed constant
epsilon there's a fixed constant
of that low energy
and we're going to show that these two
statements together
are going to imply qma equals np which
is they're going to be our contradiction
so what is the qma proof
um that the minimum energy equals zero
uh
well you could just give a state row
such that traits of h rho equals zero
right
but instead of giving the state rho
which may be very complicated
that shows that the minimum energy is
zero
because we assume the nlts conjecture is
false
we know there exists necessarily a state
sigma whose circuit complexity is a
constant
and whose energy is less than one over
20 n this is just applying the epsilon
equals 1 over 20
version of the nlps conjecture and let's
let u be the defining circuit
and now my claim is that instead of
sending the quantum state rho which is a
quantum object
approver could instead just send you the
classical description of the circuit u
now use a constant depth classical
circuit
and now what do you do well by the
previous statement if the u is a
constant depth classical circuit then we
can
calculate the energy of trace h sigma
exactly
in time
that's
polynomial and n
so if the minimum energy is zero then we
just classically check the trace of h
rho sorry excuse me traces h sigma is
less than one over twenty n
and conversely if the minimum energy was
at least one over ten n then it would
state that for all u for all circuits
that are constant depth that describe an
answer
the trace of h sigma must be at least 1
over 10 and so you wouldn't be able to
fool me because i'll be able to
calculate that
therefore instead of solving this qma
hard question
that is defined in this quantum pcp
using quantum witnesses we were able to
solve it using only classical witnesses
which gets to the fact that qma equals
np
and recall the the crux is that because
the depth of you is competent
okay so just to recap the the two facts
that were very useful for us and will be
further useful is one this notion of
litecoin
that the measurement of any
term rho only depends on the value there
and this actually
can be also used to show that statement
i've proved i stated a second ago about
being able to
calculate the energy of the local
hamiltonian
for any concept circuit in polynomial
time
the second thing we're going to need is
something about error correcting codes
right so far we've only talked about
load up circuits and that makes sense is
we're going to talk about circuit lower
bounds but the second part has to do
something with error correcting codes
because our hamiltonians are going to
arise from error correcting codes and
the property we're going to be
interested in is something we call local
and distinguishability
so local indistinguishability
says the following let s be a set of
qubits
uh where the size of s is less than d
the eraser distance so the s you can
think of as a correctable region if an
error occurred on s there exists a
method for correcting it and this can be
formalized using the canoe laphroaig
conditions which says that you can
correct an error e if you
if pi e pi is just a constant times pi
where pi is the projector of the code
space but i think of this as very
confusing and not at all intuitive so
let me try to give you a more intuitive
understanding of the statement
of focal and distinguishability so let s
be a set of two is so that x is a
correctable region
then for all code states rho
what it means is that rho when
restricted to s so that's when you trace
out everything but the region s is an
invariant no matter what code state you
started off with rho
the value of the density matrix rho on
just the region s is an invariant
now this is not a property of classical
error correction this is a property that
is
very strongly of quantum error
correction
and maybe there's an there's an
intuitive way to think about it so let's
imagine that there was an erasure error
that happened on the region s the region
s sort of fell out of your pocket and
you lost it that someone comes along
behind you and picks up the cubits that
were in the region s
right
if they were even able to partially tell
what state you started off with which
code state row you started off with then
what this would violate it would violate
the partial no cloning here
right because the no cloning theorem
says
that i can't take a state split it up
into two parts and produce the same
state again at least not generically
and because when s is a correctable
region i can reproduce the exact density
matrix from the rest of
row from row minus s then row s itself
cannot contain any information about
what state you originally started with
it's a very powerful idea this is local
and distinguishable and it's going to
come up a couple times there of course
also is a proof of this
from the canola farm conditions which
you know some people find more
satisfactory and the way you think about
that is that is any operator that only
acts on that region
then
if i was to measure trace of e row so
this is a measurement just on the qubits
of that region right that you could
write as trace e
pi row pi because
rho is a code word you can just toss in
pi's on either side if it doesn't change
anything mathematically use cyclicality
of trace to move it around
then apply the canola form condition and
get some constant so it tells you any
measurement that only acts on that
region the answer is a predetermined
constant regardless of which stick road
you start off with that's a
mathematically formal way of saving it
but the intuition about
i think no cloning is much stronger and
really gets at the heart of this
it turns out the two statements we used
this one statement about local and
distinguishability and the one statement
about litecoins is all we're going to
need
at least that's like the core of what
we're going to need to prove our
statement
so let's get to sketch of proof
techniques
so before we start let's think about
sort of what does it mean to be a low
energy state what do those states look
like it starts not as clear right
in the classical case if you take
a set of constraints and you talk about
the low energy constraints that'd be
like sort of you like physically violate
something you may flip a bit you might
violate some of the constraints if
another bit you might violate some
constraints but what we know is that in
fact the quantum world is very different
than the classical world there sort of
are these also fractional violations you
could sort of take every state and you
could sort of perturb it in like an l1
distance in the blocks sphere that adds
some error right but it's not an error
that can be discretely said as like you
violated this hamiltonian towards that
helicopter et cetera because the the the
world of low energy states is a much
much more complicated two
so in the very core of this
is the set of code states this is sort
of in the middle they're all the states
of exact energy
and then like i said there are all these
states where you take a code state
and you perturb it's likely to get to a
state row so you just move it a little
bit in the l1 distance
by at most epsilon and now the energy
with every hamiltonian term is bounded
total energy is the most desperate
they can be generalized to something
which i might call epsilon smooth states
so that the energy with every local
hamiltonian is at most epsilon so no
hamiltonian term is violated a lot
but every hamiltonian term is violated
slightly
or the other side is a very
combinatorial sort of error you take a
code word and you just completely
destroy some epsilon fraction of the
cubits and you get some sort of low
error state and you could generalize
this as some notion of combinatorial
states
where for some epsilon fraction of the
hamiltonian terms
you are completely in violation and then
there are all the states with you a
little bit about right you both
simultaneously violate some
combinatorial fraction and some smooth
fractions and they get very confusing so
that's why this world is a very
complicated parking lot
okay so if we are going to prove lower
bounds against all these states we need
to start somewhere and the place where
we're going to start are these epsilon
distances the first category i
introduced states which are close to the
code space in some physical distance but
are not exactly in it can we prove
circular rounds in just those states and
if we do does it give us any insight as
to the rest of the space that's what
we'll show in a second
so as a warm up we're going to improve
circuit lower bounds for these would
maybe you might want to call low
distance states
okay
so let's sign the estate as the distance
delta from the code word so there's a
space of code so you know just a little
bit outside
and we want to know what the circuit
complexity of size
so a focal result is that for any code
state
rho so any anything that you know
satisfies all the checks the circuit
complexity scales with log d you can
prove this
in a myriad of ways but one thing that
has happened is we're going to prove a
circular lower bound for low distance
states in this warm up alone and that
will subsume it so just take my word for
it or if you don't you will have proved
it again
in just about two minutes
and for simplicity for now let's just
consider pure states and circuits
without incillus i promise you that all
these statements that we're going to
show do work when the states aren't pure
and the circuits are known as facilities
but for now let's just consider this
simplified manner
and here's the theorem we can prove
so if the square root of delta is less
than the code rate the relative rate k
over n
then for any state psi there's a
distance delta from the code the circuit
complexity of sky a psi
is logarithmic in the distance so that's
the fact that we're going to be able to
easily show for all low distances and
again for for just this warm up let's
consider just
psi being pure and the circuit lower
bound is on circuits without infillis
the general results in our papers
both consider mixed states and circuits
with control
so how do we show this theorem well
we're going to use all the tools we've
built so far and one
combination so here's how we do it
so let's just define the let's give the
name
row to the state which is closest
um
to psi but is a code word so that's
where row sits
and we're going to let theta be the
encoded maximum mixed state so right
it's just the
um
it's like you encoded the maximum mixed
state is one way to look at it or you
can just think of it as the mixture over
all the states in there this is like the
uniform probably distribution over all
states of the code
okay
and now let r be a region such the size
of ours and d or the correctable region
okay and now let's notice two properties
the reduced density matrix of psi on
that region r
is delta close to
the reduced density
under
tracing out regions
and the second part we're going to use
is local indistinguishability which says
that rho on a small on a correctable
region r is exactly equivalent to theta
on that corresponding region
okay and now we have to assume something
for the purpose of contradiction about
psi so let's assume psi is the output of
a circuit mu and use a short bet it's a
depth t where two to the t is less than
v so that's why this is an orange this
is going to be what our we're going to
assume for the purpose of contradiction
what that means though is if i apply
u inverse or u dagger to psi
right i get back
the all zero state
or another way of saying that is for any
qubit i
to trace
when i just look at the value of the i
cubit of u dagger psi u
that is exactly equal to zero
okay
and now let's do something fun this is
the big equation that's basically the
heart of the proof
so on one side here we have zero zero
equals trace on the i cubit of u dagger
psi u this first equation well this is
just actually just step two in disguise
right this is just me rewriting step two
okay
the next one this equality
is where i've used the fact about like
tones we talked about earlier
that if i'm just interested in the value
of the eyes qubit i can just think of
psi not not just psi but psi restricted
to the electron li
and now
i get to use in
the approximation the delta
approximation given fact one
right because
the like cone is going to have size less
than b why because two to the t is less
than d so it itself is a correctable
region so fact one tells me that this
is delta close to the value when i
replace it with theta
and now i undo the same light code
statement to get the result on the
outside and now if i look at the
statement from the outside what i get is
that
the i cubit of
rotated theta so if i take theta and i
rotate it by the matrix by the unitary u
and i look at the eyes cubits that thing
is really close to zero zero it's delta
cos
right i just kind of put together all
the facts i know all in one go
and what does that tell me well if that
qubit is really close to zero zero then
the entropy of that rotated is cubit is
not too high it's at most square root
delta or more precisely delta log one
over delta but let's just say root build
okay but here's something fun
the
total
entropy
of rotated theta of u
of u daggers theta u
that's going to be equal to k the rate
of the code why because entropy doesn't
change
with unitary operations and the entropy
of theta is k because it's the maximally
mixed state the encoded maximum mixtape
and now using the trivial bound on
entropy that the entropy of a state is
bounded by the entropy of the sum of it
on smaller registers
i guess this equation 5 that k is less
than or equal to
root delta times n but this is precisely
contradicts our assumption that root
delta is less than k over n right so
what is the only thing we assume the
thing is in orange that two to the t is
less than d so this gives us a lower
bound
of
log d
in fact it gives us exactly log b where
the log is longer than base two
so very simple proof it tells us exactly
what we need on how to prove circuit
lower bound schematics
okay kind of cool
but
we look back at our picture of the phase
of low energy states and it's really
really big right it doesn't this this
fact about one thing isn't really
telling us about the rest
so how do we extend the argument from
just the low distance states which is
just a small section of the status flow
energy to all the low energy states
okay
so what we're going to need to do is
actually introduce something a bit more
so what we previously said was true just
of any error correcting code anything
that satisfies the canola form
conditions now we're going to be a
little specific and talk about ldpc
stabilizer codes
so these are codes where all the checks
are tens of products of constant number
of powerless
and what we notice is that the code
space is the set that satisfies all the
uh all the checks so every check ci
equals psi
um but we can also define just like the
code space we can define all the eigen
spaces and i'm going to call these ds's
where s is a string and it indicates
which eigen space i'm interested in
thinking about and it's just
these sort of parallel eigens uh not
parallel excuse me just uh different
subspaces right
where d0 is exactly the code space
and what one can show and i won't do
this for the interest of time in this
top
but that local and distinguishability
the property that we showed was
necessary for all error correcting codes
in the case of ldpc stabilizer codes is
a property held not only by the code
space but also by every eigenspace
now what the invariant what row is row r
the invariant that can vary depending
upon which
eigenspace you're talking about but
within the eigenspace row r is an
invariant whenever r is a correctable
reach
and this property is sort of what's
going to be able to help us lift the
idea from low distance states to all
states at a very high level here's sort
of what we're going to do
as any state can sort of be decomposed
into its components into each of these
eigen spaces
right um
it uh i can just sort of write it as you
know
based on the projection of each of the
eigen spaces
now eigen space by eigenspace i'm going
to be able to use the local and
distinguishability argument in the same
way as i did for the low distance states
and then i'm going to sort of add up all
those things together so i sort of did
the argument in the previous slide for
just
the eigenspace corresponding to s equals
zero and now i'm going to show that you
can generalize this to all the eigen
spaces simultaneously and do the
argument very clearly up there
so here's just the statement of the main
theorem once more that we're going to
show
okay
so
one key idea we're going to use
something that's referred to as gentle
measurement which is the idea that if
my measurement was guaranteed
so if i'm going to make a measurement
that succeeds with very high probability
the act of performing the measurement
is not very perturbative
right you can sort of think of it as
like imagine you had two vectors here
and i was trying to measure the state
that's right here the measurement most
of the time will just collapse the state
from here to here but in a very rare
probability it moves the state all the
way back up
right but the overall density matrix and
the in the normal density matrices was
not very far from the original state to
the post-measurement state
and in fact if the measurement was going
to succeed with probability 1 minus
epsilon then the
the measurement is not too perturbative
it's only epsilon perturbative sort of
the formal motion
so if i have a state phi and n qubit now
i'm just going to talk about mixed
states so i and u being a depth t
circuit here now it's going to be able
to be a circle within phillips
um that constructs phi
i can sort of define the energy per
hamiltonian term as epsilon i now what
does it mean for it to be a low energy
state it means that the sum of epsilon
i's
is bounded by epsilon times the total
number n
and we assume without loss of generality
that the circuit u acts on n times two
to the t cubic anymore then you can just
truncate it to find a simpler circuit
because of couples
now given five i'm going to define two
states one called little side one called
capital psi and all that's going to be
is i'm just going to coherently measure
each stabilizer term into an extra
ancilla
or i'm going to incoherently measure so
coherently measurements i copy it but i
don't actually you know perform the
perturbative measurement and capital phi
is where i do perform the perturbative
measurement
the high level idea is that little phi
and capital phi are not going to be too
far off
because they only differ by perturbative
measurements that are overall fairly
gentle
so here's sort of you can think about it
is the circuit u acted on insulin code
cubits to build the state phi then i
measure into this extra blue register
these syndrome measurements to create
psi and then i incoherently measure that
one more time to get capital psi
now since phi had a load f circuit
then psi also has a load up circuit the
depth is going to be t plus the fixed
constant
the fixed constant here will depend on
the ldpc-ness of the code
so precisely the gentle measurement idea
that i wanted to state one way to write
is in terms of fidelity
it says for any region r of the cubits
the fidelity between little psi on that
region and capital sign that region is
very close to one so it's nearly perfect
and it differs based on the sum over
this number of the epsilons of the
syndromes that are within that
measurement so if the regions have a lot
of measurements in that rate in between
them
then the fidelity could be far but if
there's very few measurements then the
fidelities can't differ by too much
and this is roughly the idea of gentle
measurements i'm not going to go into
the technical detail there
oh sorry rough gentle measurements and
commuting
gentle measurements
excuse me
so now just like the previous example we
need to somehow introduce entropy
so we're going to call that capital size
the incoherently measured version of phi
and so what we'll do is we'll introduce
the completely
logical completely deco
curing channel
which is basically the same we just need
to somehow create the version of the
mixtape and what that's exactly what i'm
going to call it i'm going to use the
same greek variable so i'm going to
define capital theta
as applying this logically completely
deco curing channel
to psi so that gives me the entropy of
theta
is going to be at least k
and why did i do this why did i apply
this
logically completely decorating channel
it's because i want to be able to make
the statement in point two
that for any correctable reason r
that psi and theta look identical with
respect to that region r
and here's where the local and
distinguishability for eigenspace comes
in
and both capital sine and theta are cq
state classical quantum states with the
same distribution
okay
so now let's put together the point so
the one was the fidelity between little
psi and capital psi
is nearly optimal and the second one is
to be ex the density matrices on
correctible regions look exact
so
and then the third point we're going to
use
is that since
little psi was constructable by a
constant f circuit that if i was to undo
that constant of circuit w
then i get back to the cube of zero
right and now here's what i do is i
assume
for contradiction that two to the t
plus some constant is at most the
distance
then i get to the fidelity
between the jth cubit of rotated psi and
the j cube of rotated theta
well that's equivalent to the fidelity
of the jth cubit of rotating
of rotated psi only on the light cone
and rotated beta only on the light
column right but that's a small
correctable region so this is one minus
the sum over epsilon i the summation
being over all the syndrome measurements
so just
excluded from brevity and this is a
consequence of steps one and two
so now i have the fidelity between the
zero cubit
and the j cubed of rotated theta is
really close to one
right it's
one minus the sum over epsilon i where
epsilons are from the like cone of j
cubit
and what that sort of morally tells me
is that in expectation it's pretty
close to zero right because the
expectation of this
is on the order of two to the t times
epsilon
so
what i get is the entropy of the j cubit
for most cubits
scales roughly like 2 to the t times
epsilon
at most and then i do the same sort of
argument i did previously
you know i want to calculate the total
entropy with the total entropy is at
least k
and i can bound it nicely by the sum of
the entropies on each of the qubits one
after another
and i sort of put together the arguments
carry the two to the t's you know move
stuff around and i get order two to the
two to the t n epsilon times log one
over epsilon now where this two to the t
term comes that didn't exist in the
previous argument well that comes from
the fact that the light cones are size
true to the p we weren't able to do as
clean an argument because we aren't able
to bound the size of a light cone and
show that each qubit doesn't affect more
than two to the t times
as many cubes as very systems
and so then you put this all together
you reverse the statement and you get
the balance that we want in our main
theorem some small cleanups later you
basically have the version that's in the
paper
um and again there are two assumptions
which is why t is greater than the
middle of two statements
one is log d which is we had to assume
for calculating the fidelities
and the second one is due to the bound
on the rate so we had to make two
assumptions right the log d came from
two to the t is less than d
so our argument recap if you have an
ldpc stabilized code
and finds the depth to state then we're
able to prove a lower bound and the idea
is roughly as follows since it's ldpc
you can measure all the terms in
constant up circuit
and then you use local and
distinguishability to show on average
that the maximally mixed state on a
correctable region is close to sign that
region right and then using the low
depth nature of psi
and phi you bound the entropy of theta
which yields the contradiction because
theta is both a high entropy state and a
bounded entropy state
so that's all for this version of the
talk
for more open questions please visit us
during the itcs section and i look
forward to seeing you